Let's see how you did. If you have a pair of jeans that a store paid $23 for and
they mark it up by 32%, customers will pay $30.36. Let's see how we got 30.36.
Well we know the original price of the jeans was $23 and they were marked up by
32%. Since they were marked up, we add 32% to 100% So 100 percent plus
32 percent is 132%.
Remember when you do problems with percents, they, you always have to convert
the percentage to a decimal. To convert 132 percent to a decimal, we have to
move the decimal over two places. So 132 percent is 1.32.
Now, we just have to multiply 23 times 1.32, and when you multiply those
together, you get 30.36. Now, one thing to keep in mind is whenever you're
solving word problems, you have to remember to put units. So, in this case,
we're talking about dollars, so the answer is going to be $30.36. Don't forget
to put the dollar sign.